was thinking about the problems that
women will talk about in their
relationships and I was thinking and
this was kind of like a red a concept
guy to be red pills on if women are
arguing with their husbands that is the
fault of the woman well it's both of
their faults but the question is why are
you arguing with your husband now this
might sound crazy to those of you
getting red pill but if you if you've
heard your parents argue before or your
friends or maybe you've argued it's the
woman's fault now it's the man's fault
for putting up with it and not
establishing say like boundaries in a
relationship that sort of thing but when
you think about it if you have a boss
that's arguing with an employee the
problem is the employee like they're not
supposed to argue with the boss they're
supposed to follow orders even if they
disagree and that's the problem with
women today